I think you can too plays a big role in
people's lives I think it's important
for people to be able to sit down
together and enjoy a show about the
things that they love whether it's
movies music and even just the
celebrities that they love to follow
season 15 is a landmark for Canadian
television for et Canada to have been
around this long excelling at what they
do what we do for this long is
incredible there have been so many
amazing any because I've done cher was
an incredible moment
Dolly Parton was phenomenal one as well
and even a lot of our younger stars
especially hipping Candice Shawn Mendes
talking to him it's really been a blast
and granted only how are you buddy
thanks man you know when I sat down with
Shawn Mendes for the very first time it
was like the mutual appreciation club
because I thought what he was doing was
so phenomenal and he said straight up to
me it was like yeah I how was a big
Daddy or is growing up that was very
cool I was expecting when you Harlow's
have kind of the same reaction as well
she kind of like kicked that a little
bit I mean I'm assuming you know as
Aladdin we did a very special thing
where we flew in a helicopter to his
hometown and on the way up we talked
about what it was like growing up in
southern Ontario him watching me on TV
and we sang a whole new world together
it was beautiful beautiful thing
[Music]
I've been a fan of Ryan's for a very
long time only eg came today is in Tokyo
Japan with Ryan Reynolds that interview
in Japan was actually really phenomenal
that was a very cool experience and to
get to do that interview in a place
where I've always dreamt of going was
like checking like a million things off
my bucket list as far as world premieres
go here in Tokyo I mean how is this this
is not bad at all
yeah Japan does it right yes surreal one
of the most amazing moments I've
actually had here Sharon and Bram from
Sharon Louis and Bramblett came into the
e to Canada studio he sat down we did an
interview and we got to sing
skinnamarinky do get it it was amazing
animal rinky dinky dink skinnamarinky do
you I would love to see fifty more
seasons of et Canada that long 15 this
sparkle behind the story is brought to
you by sparkling ice fruity flavorful
sparkling water
you